[Applause]
[Music]
we've got another month of summer which
means plenty of hot games are still
releasing you know that pun looked a lot
better on paper but hey there are still
plenty of games dropping this week so
let's take a look at some of the heavy
hitters Tacoma comes from the same team
behind gone home and its latest
narrative exploration game is literally
out of this world
Tacoma is the name of the abandoned
Space Station you'll be exploring with
less sticky notes on the fridge and more
full-on Holograms and science videos
there will be plenty of mysteries to
uncover two hundred thousand miles from
Earth when Tacoma launches on PC and
Xbox one on Wednesday August 2nd and if
you hit that subscribe button you'll get
our full video review delivered right to
you when it's ready
what's an episode of new releases
without a little violence as Tess has
that covered and it's wicked art style
certainly doesn't hurt this is a part
strategy game part beat'em up about
Aztecs defending their land from Spanish
conquistadors you'll manage the whole
conflict on a tile based board but when
it comes to individual battles you'll
zoom in on the action for some
spectacularly bloody 2-d fights and
thanks to a hefty variety of weapons and
environments you can change it up every
time you defend your land as tez hits PC
on Monday July 31st new releases also
feels incomplete without a vr game so
let's take care of that with Dino
frontier it's all about managing a
frontier settlement but instead of
raising cattle
you'll be hoarding dinosaurs thanks to
PlayStation VR you'll be reaching into
the world to interact with your town the
townspeople and their dinosaur helpers
you can strap in on Tuesday August 1st
hopefully you'll be able to replicate
the best scene from Jurassic Park
speaking of PlayStation Patapon
remastered is bringing the PSP favorite
to the current generation the original
game is getting bumped all the way up to
4k so things will look very pretty as
you drum out your rhythmic marching
orders 30 missions and a handful of
minigames means you'll have plenty of
options for sending troops into battle
and you can give them all a try on the
first and finally let's slow things down
a bit with shadow tactics blades of the
Shogun which is making its console debut
on Xbox one and ps4 the stealthy tactics
game is loosely based on the Japanese
Edo period and you have a variety of
samurai at your disposal from shuriken
throwing high ATO to the sniper rifle
wielding Takuma you can set out to stop
your rival warlords on the first and
those are some of the hottest games
we'll be playing this week as always
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change and don't forget you can always
grab the game spot now app on iOS and
Android to keep up with all the top
stories and games every day thanks for
watching guys and I'll be back with more
games next week